with her loader on its way to kavik sue
attempted to meet the convoy to guide
them to camp safely but dangerous
conditions forced her to return home and
checking on the status and safety of the
delivery crew is a priority hack a cold
I mean coming in we dropped in
temperature severely in the end I mean I
feel bad that I didn't get out there but
I'm not gonna be much help to anybody if
I can't keep myself safe you don't
really want to rub your hands together
and I'm cold I personally haven't frozen
my fingers that hard I don't think ever
better go call Jim hey buddy how you
doing I'm doing good yourself oh man you
know I went out there and tried to meet
up with the convoy and it's so damn
foggy I don't even have 200 yards of
visibility and look yeah I saw it went
for five miles and I'm like man I'm
gonna I'm gonna get frostbite and that
won't help anybody out well I just
talked to them okay and I figure there's
between three and five miles away from
me all right buddy well I'll keep an eye
out for him and I'll just send you an
email then when they get in just so you
know all right thank you Trudy
all righty talk to you later
I'll shoot the cat training myself were
probably right next to each other and he
says they're three or five miles out
that's exactly where I was visibility's
so poor we couldn't see each other so
but even at that distance away they may
shut her down and get some rest
safety safety safety they've got their
little travel trailer they can handle
that I'll be here whenever it's just
hurry up and wait